good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
on the railways on the road
and in the skies britain faces a summer
of travel troubles as the cost of living
crisis continues to bite thousands of
rail workers could be about to walk out
in the biggest strike
since 1989 nazar's petrol prices have
hit a new eye-watering record high this
time last year you'd pay one prime 30 or
thereabouts a liter now you could be
paying two pounds a liter at the pumps
at some four cores we'll ask the
government what they're going to do
about it as they try to put the
confidence vote behind them and focus
instead on issues just like those
but will there be tax cuts to help the
health secretary said you javid on the
show shortly plus the conservative peer
baroness altman who's got a view on what
the future holds for the prime minister
it is wednesday the 8th of june
pushed into a corner as thousands of
rail workers prepare for the biggest
strike since 1989 the government says
it's disappointing
boris johnson prepares to face
parliament for the first time since a
damaging revolt by his own mps under
pressure to cut taxes
two british fighters captured by russian
forces and accused of being mercenaries
appear in court with a moroccan man on
charges that carry a possible death
penalty
hope of a future the ukrainian teenager
returns to her destroyed school in the
dress she planned to wear to the prom
that never happened
here in washington the gun debate comes
to capitol hill with politicians in here
hearing from the survivors of that day
in uvalde and as they do an emotional
plea from an actor at the white house
these are the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
i'm at a fish and chip shop in central
london where the industry is turning to
scandinavia to help solve soaring
costs to save businesses like this one
with petrol prices at a new high i'll
ask the executive director of the petrol
retailers association that's gordon
obama how much worse it could get
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world
[Music]
and running up that chart at first for
an old classic thanks to a new lease of
life
[Music]
and saving our seas will speak to the
co-founder of an ocean protection
charity to mark world oceans day
[Music]
very good morning everybody the prime
minister will face parliament for the
first time since monday's rebellion by
mps from his own party when he squares
up for pmqs this lunchtime boris johnson
says he wants to focus on real issues
he's under pressure to cut tax to help
with the cost of living crisis
people are facing a miserable summer of
travel trouble with petrol prices
skyrocketing delays and cancellations at
airports forecast to drag on for months
and potentially the biggest rail strike
in more than 30 years on the cards in
just under two weeks time
shingi maruiki reports
it could be the biggest outbreak of
industrial action in a generation from
swindon to manchester london to
edinburgh
three days of strikes across 13 networks
planned to bring britain's railways to a
standstill
the general secretary of the union
behind the movement says after two years
of talks they've been left with no
choice
we've had to take that action because of
the agenda that the companies have put
before us which is thousands of job cuts
stripping out our terms and conditions
and the refusal to make a pay offer
after
two and sometimes three years this will
obviously impact lots of people who will
be using the rail networks to get to
work on those free days what would you
say to those people impacted we feel
that we have to make a stand we have to
make a stand in defense of safety in
defense of jobs
conditions and pay
fifty thousand rail workers are to walk
out as part of the biggest national
strike in the uk since 1989.
the dates june 21st 23rd and 25th
the national union of real maritime and
transport workers says the cost of
living crisis job cuts and pay freezes
are the driving force
and they want their pay to be at least
in line with inflation which currently
stands at nine percent
the government is calling for compromise
and common sense between both sides if a
solution cannot be reached it will be
passengers across the country who bear
the brunt of that disruption
it's totally inconvenience to be honest
i mean
trying to get to and from
it's a nightmare if that's the only way
they're going to be listened to
then so be it
somebody has to be held to account the
people are trying to affect they're not
affected by it us like commoners who are
trying to get to work you now have to
leave like three like an hour earlier
the rail industry bodies feel the
negotiating table
not strike action should be the next
destination
we have not said we are not going to
give staff a pay increase but we need to
sit down and talk with our mt and how we
can move reform forward to make it fair
for everybody
if that doesn't happen we stand on the
brink of three days of travel chaos and
disruption in nearly every corner of the
country
shinki maurike sky news houston station
in central london
joining us now the health section is
sajin javid twice in a week you're
spoiling me mr javid um talk to me about
this new nhs report uh leaders praise
for their dedication but it does find
that bullying discrimination and
shifting the blame when things go wrong
arrive in the nhs why is that
well today we're announcing what i think
is the biggest shake-up in leadership in
the nhs and social care generation it
follows this independent review by
general sir gordon messenger and and why
we've done this is really we're
investing record amounts in the nhs and
care and to help with the recovery from
the pandemic it's important that we have
good leadership throughout the nhs and
care so that every pound is spent well
on patients priorities and what this
report shows is that i mean first of all
and that's the best news is that there
are fantastic examples throughout the
nhs in care of of great leadership and i
see that almost every day but there are
also examples of of poor leadership and
that leads to poor patient outcomes so
it gives a number of recommendations on
how good leadership can be made more
consistent throughout the country it
also to your point uh it gives evidence
uh unfortunately of in some cases of
poor behavior a bit of a blame culture
in in certain parts and and of course
that can't be tolerated so i'm going to
accept all the recommendations of this
independent report and that's because i
know that it's going to lead to a
significant improvement across the board
in leadership and management in the nhs
and care which most importantly means an
improvement in patient outcomes okay now
i'm sure you'll see in this morning's
papers that uh
nhs advice on ovarian cancer on the
website has dropped the reference to it
affecting women what it actually says
now is ovarian cancer affects the two
small organs ovaries that store the eggs
needed to make babies why the change
well look um i i haven't seen that
particular report but i have heard of
instances like that and i don't think
it's right you know you won't be
surprised to know that as the health
secretary i think that your uh that your
your sex matters your biological sex is
incredibly important to make sure you
get the right treatment the very best
treatment you've given an example of
ovarian cancer i could equally uh pick a
prostate cancer which which we know can
only happen for those that are
biologically male and so
it's important that that when messaging
is is given to people you know for
cancers that's a great example that
you've picked that that words like women
and men are used so that people know who
you're talking about and and then we can
actually do something about it are you
going to get the wording change back
then
i i am looking into this and you all
know look the nhs there are many
different trusts and and i want to
listen to why someone might have taken a
different approach i don't just want to
assume but i think i've made my views
clear on this yeah but it's actually on
the nhs website so you know and and as
we both know as many of our viewers will
know ovarian cancer is a silent killer
generally a lot of women don't that
kills a lot of women in their 30s 40s
50s because they don't know they've got
it until they're at stage four and then
there's nothing that can be done about
it when you have confusing wording like
that it's just not going to help so
don't you think well i'm guessing what
you're saying
yeah go on okay look i i agree and uh
and also you know a few months back a
similar issue came up over cervical uh
cancer where you know i saw some
in that case it was it was draft
literature around getting more uh women
encouraging to come in for smear tests
and and it was important
of course to talk about women when
you're talking about cervical cancer and
believe it or not there are women out
there that don't know always that when
you're talking about cervixes and things
you're actually talking about women and
and the way you do that is make sure
that you're using the right and the
sensible words so okay i know there's
some sensitivity around this language
but we have to use common sense and use
the right language so that we can give
people the best possible patient care
okay so that wording should be changed
back let's wait and see what happens
thanks for the clarification on that
health secretary uh rail strikes let's
talk about those three in a week at the
end of the month it's going i mean we're
just trying to get ourselves back on our
feet as a country and as an economy
what's the government going to do about
it
look
we obviously don't agree with this
decision of the unions i think it's it's
not just clearly a bad outcome for
travellers if these strikes went ahead i
actually think it's bad for for the
workers because
you need it and have an industry that's
that's going to be sustainable
we know as a result of the pandemic
there are some habits that that are
developed and things might not go quite
back to what they were pre pandemic and
and let's remember during the pandemic i
think the government put in some extra
16 billion pounds to support the rail
industry that's almost something like
600 pounds per household these are these
are huge amounts of money and that kind
of thing can't continue so what i would
urge the industry uh to do and and and
the unions is to basically just get
round the table and keep talking that's
the best way just talk like you civilize
adults and find a way through i think
everyone can understand each other and
these are challenging times but talk
what about fuel up to two pounds at
least now this time last year it was one
time 30 a liter the government making
something like 26 billion pounds in fuel
duty is it time to look at cutting uh
the price the fuel duty further i know
you've already done five pence a liter
well what we know that the fuel duty was
as you mentioned it was cut very
recently by the chancellor that's the
biggest cut and
fuel detail i can ever remember and and
that does cost the treasury billions and
and and and i hear what you say about
your fuel duty raises i think you said
26 billion or thereabouts but you know
at the end of the day we also have to
remember that uh you know i'm standing
in this hospital today and i talked
about investing billions in in nhs and
care the nhs's budget uh this year is
something like 160 billion pounds and
that money has to come from somewhere so
it is right that we keep all taxes and
duties under review especially when
people are facing the cost of living
challenges it's right that we cut fuel
duty by 5p and i'm sure the chance will
be looking to do whatever else can be
afforded in
time
now i know you'll want to address this
allegation that labour's put forward
today so allow me to give you the
opportunity to do that they say they've
unearthed evidence of you avoiding
hundreds of thousands of pounds in tax
before you got into politics did you
well no of course not you know this is
typical labor you know personal attacks
on on people and this is what labor does
when they've got nothing to say about
the the real issues the issues at hand
you know what i yeah i think what people
want to know from labor is you know what
are their plans to deal with the nhs you
know kobe backlogs what are their plans
to help with cost living what are their
plans for growth in the economy this is
just typical smear attacks by labor and
it's nothing more
okay what they say is that uh records
showed that you were a director of a
company set up by your brother for a
single day in may of 2005
and then you
gave up yours and your wife's shares
during that year sa capital raised
almost a million pounds in loans there
were only 411 000 was secured from banks
leaving 585 000 to unaccounted for 2005
accounts also show that 491 thousand
pound was lent to an unknown party
the suggestion being that if the purpose
of the loans was to provide a tax
efficient way for money held offshore to
enter britain is that nonsense or is
there some uh truth in that well what i
i've i've been very clear about my own
tax affairs my tax states my residences
when i've worked in the uk when i've
worked abroad i've been very clear and
open about that and at all times i've
been clear that your all rules of course
have always uh been followed and what
labor
what you're referring to in in this
letter is this is just a typical sort of
labor smear campaign where they don't
have any evidence on anything and
they're just making things up so that
they can launch personal attacks that's
all it is let me ask you one more on
that and then we'll move on to the prime
minister if i may so 585 000 pounds
unaccounted for is the suggestion there
and potentially the purpose of the loans
to provide a tax efficient way for money
held offshore to enter britain is there
any truth at all in that allegation
no i've what i what i've been uh clear
about and as i've said i've been very
open about
about all of this is that and yesterday
when i was asked about this for for the
first time uh is that you know some 20
years ago uh i did i invested in my
brother's business to help him start a
new business of course i did and i don't
think there's anything
wrong with that i think that's something
that many people will do to help out
their siblings or or loved ones in
starting their own business or their
enterprise and and that's all there is
uh to this that's all there is
okay so there was no way that money was
coming in from offshore without paying
the tax on it okay uh talk to me about
the um
prime minister and suggestions that he's
potentially going to promote he's going
to have a reshuffle i know you won't
comment on reshuffle but suggestions
that he is potentially going to promote
people who have been incredibly
supportive
publicly and privately over the last few
weeks does in your experience does the
prime minister
prioritize loyalty
over experience
the the
i mean first of all this is just all
speculation again we we've had a a a a a
very important week uh obviously with
that important vote it was a clear and
decisive win uh for the prime minister
and and and speaking to colleagues here
after that vote yesterday including some
that that i spoke to that that publicly
said they didn't support the prime
minister and the vote but you know
they're democrats like all of us and
they accept the result of the vote and
they're getting behind the prime
minister and what the prime minister
does next in terms of uh his you know
his cabinet his ministers that's of
course that's as always any promise
that's just a decision for them i'm not
spending any time speculating or
thinking about that i'm just getting on
with my job as the health and care
secretary and that's why i was here
today to talk about this new leadership
review indeed so that's exactly why i
said to you i wasn't expecting you to
comment on it but nevertheless my
question was does the pm prioritize
loyalty over experience we've seen him
do it in the past in some of the
high offices of state is it your
experience that he prioritizes loyalty
but my experience is that he wants the
best people
in the right roles so that we can get on
with dealing with the huge challenges
especially post pandemic we face
as a country that's why i think for
example i was asked to to step into this
role it's for me it's the is that it's
the toughest job i've done in government
so far uh but it's also i'd say was one
of the most rewarding or the most
privileged to work with such incredible
people but to help to deal with such
important challenges before i let you go
um is it right that the 1922 committee
could look again at the rules to change
the rules so instead of the prime
minister having a year's grace before he
would face any further um
challenges against him it could be
reduced to six months is it right that
they move the goal posts
you know
i i'm not sure uh to to perfectly
honestly i'm not an expert on
on the rules around the 22 uh committee
what i do know is that the the the rules
uh as they stand uh that uh that
you can't have another vote uh for a
year but look i mean
as i say i'm not an expert on the rules
but i i think right here and now that
we've had had this uh ballot it was done
properly in a completely fair
transparent way the party of war has
expressed confidence in the prime
minister at his time now just to unite
and to get on with the job i didn't
think you were going to say that i
thought you were going to say absolutely
not he's won the vote and he's safe for
a year
well i that's he i've just said to you
he's won the vote uh he's got the
confidence uh of the of the majority of
mps and that's how this works no prime
minister i've known in the past has had
the confidence 100
of mps there's a democratic uh decision
and that's why we're going to get on for
the with the job you know for
for the years to come but you know let's
just get on with it i think that's what
people want to see i know you've got to
go but i just to clarify that i'm not
sure what what did you mean when you
said you're not sure whether they should
look again at it
no i thought you asked me what the are
they able uh to change the rules and my
answer to that
i'm not sure about the rules yeah they
can if they want to well
if you're i'll take your word for it i i
i'm just not an expert on the 22 rules
so i'm not going to talk about something
i don't know about
should they change the real system of
course they should okay i
of course they shouldn't change the
rules i thought you were asking me
whether they can change the words but uh
yeah there's no need to change any rules
because we've had the ballot it's a
clear decisive result and now we just
get on with the job oh i'm glad we
cleared that up that would have been a
headline later on today thank you very
much indeed for joining us health
secretary as always thank you thank you
thank you thank you
looking at the front pages for you some
of which are reacting to the rail strike
announcement including the metro which
highlights that the planned walkout will
impact revelers heading to glastonbury
the daily mail has labelled the strike
hard left adding it hasn't been
condemned by labour
the telly telegraph reports that boris
johnson is being urged by allies to
offer jeremy hunt the job of chancellor
to stabilize his leadership and heal
rifts with the tory party
the sun leads on two pounds elite petrol
prices suggesting the only option this
summer will be to sit out in the garden
and the mirror asks why can't someone
sort this out as airport chaos continues
and of course boris johnson will be
attending his first pm queues today
since the confidence vote you can watch
that live here on sky news from midday
today
in other news two british fighters
captured by russian forces and accused
of being mercenaries for ukrainian
forces have appeared in court with a
moroccan man on charges that carry a
possible death penalty
it's believed aiden aslina and sean
pinner were part of the regular
ukrainian military units in mariopol in
a statement mr aslan's family said they
are working with the foreign office and
ukrainian government to get him home
they added this is a very sensitive and
emotional time for our family and we
would like to say thank you to all that
have supported us
aiden is a much loved man and very much
missed and we hope that he will be
released very soon
russian foreign ministry sergey lavrov
foreign minister i should say sergey
lavrov will meet his turkish counterpart
later with talks about opening a black
sea corridor for ukrainian grain exports
to be on the agenda ukraine is one of
the biggest exporters of grain in the
world the country's president vladimir
zelensky says he wants security
guarantees for ukrainian ships so that
22 to 25 million tons of blocked grain
could be exported and prevent food
shortages in africa and asia
now here's a powerful image for you from
ukraine a young woman has returned to
the wreckage of her now destroyed school
in her prom dress on the day the dance
was supposed to take place the story
posted on facebook by the ukrainian
government comes from anna epischeva who
shared an image of her niece
in the red gown
still to come on the programme for you
as russia moves closer to capturing the
donbass region we'll speak to the former
commander of the joint forces command
general richard barrons
with monkey pox now
designated i should say a notifiable
disease we'll speak to infectious
diseases expert dr charlotte hammer
and also chatting to the president of
the national federation of fish fryers
andrew crook who's in norway to plead
for help as skyrocketing fish prices
threaten many businesses
no matter what time of day is you could
always eat fish and chips couldn't you
now 700 people have died of gun violence
in the u.s since the texas school
shooting two weeks ago the hollywood
star matthew mcconaughey has made an
impassioned plea for reforms to u.s gun
laws after 19 students and two teachers
were killed in a school shooting in his
hometown of uvalde last month
later this afternoon u.s politicians
will hear what's expected to be powerful
testimony from some of the survivors
the latest data lays bare the scale of
gun violence in the u.s according to
research from the gun violence archive
there have been gun killings in 43 of
the 50 u.s states in the two weeks since
the texas school shooting
more than 650 incidents have resulted in
730 deaths in this period
of those deaths 23 were children more
than the total number who died in uvalde
and 66 were teenagers here's mark stone
from washington
thank you here we go there are moments
at this white house podium which
resonate they are remembered and this
may well be one of them
to make the loss
of these lives matter
not a president but an actor angry
hurting and with a pair of shoes that
belonged to one of the 19 children
killed in his hometown
green high top converse
wore these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
with his wife he has spent much of the
past week with the families of those who
died in a week where lawmakers on
capitol hill are trying to see if they
can agree on new gun laws he urged for
unity and sense
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
responsible gun owners
are fed up
with the second amendment being abused
and hijacked by some deranged
individuals
these regulations are not a step back
their step forward for civil society and
and the second amendment he's a gun
owner himself he acknowledged as much
but insisted that there is a way forward
there is not a democratic or republican
value in one single act of these
shooters it's not
but people in power
have failed to act so we're asking you
and i'm asking you will you please ask
yourselves
can both sides rise above
can both sides see beyond the political
problem at hand and admit that we have a
life preservation problem on our hands
and he's not wrong in the two weeks
since uvalde more than 700 people have
been shot dead in america 66 of them
teenagers 23 of them children it is the
politicians in here who are responsible
for pushing through change or not it is
on their shoulders and later today they
will hear from the parents and the
survivors of that day in new valde
they will include mia cerrillo 11 years
old she covered herself in blood and
play dead in order to live
mark stone sky news in washington
can you imagine being that age and
having to think on your feet and cover
yourself in blood so that you don't get
killed it's going to stay with her
forever isn't it
also making news
concerns are growing for a missing
british journalist and local indigenous
expert who were
seen in the amazon rainforest brazilian
police have now opened
a criminal investigation into the
disappearance of dom phillips and bruno
pereira
they had received threats from illegal
loggers and miners just day before they
won't miss it
two people in a boat in a region like
that completely wild it is not a
recommended adventure anything can
happen an accident they might have been
executed anything can happen we expect
and ask god that they can be found soon
the army is working very hard in the
region
a plane carrying the earl encounters of
wessex has been forced to make an
unscheduled landing during a technical
issue
prince edward and his wife sophie were
on their way to visit gibraltar to mark
the queen's platinum jubilee when their
flight was disrupted at the last minute
it comes a week after the queen's jet
was forced to abort its landing as she
returned from aberdeen to london ahead
of her platinum jubilee celebrations
in football england narrowly avoided two
defeats in a row when they faced germany
in munich in the uefa nations league
jonas hoffman opened the scoring for
germany in the 51st minute
and 88th minute penalty there from
captain harry kane rescued a point and a
small amount of pride for england
about 4 000 england fans were in munich
for the game seven were arrested
following incidents on monday night
kate bush has earned her first ever u.s
top 10 hit with running up that hill
nearly 40 years after it was first
released
[Music]
why is it suddenly so popular you asked
well fans of the netflix show stranger
things will know that it's one of the
main soundtracks used in the latest
series which was released less than two
weeks ago here it is in action
[Music]
well without giving too much away this
song is particularly important to that
character max
of course kate bush is thrilled and has
said it's really exciting to see the
song being given a new lease of life by
stranger things fans a show she says she
loves too
i haven't seen it so i can't comment i
know i'm the only person in the world
that hasn't seen it but i haven't
quit look at the weather let's see if
it's
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Music]
heavy showers or longer spells of rain
today before turning unseasonably windy
by friday especially in the northwest
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
some of you may have seen my interview
with the deputy prime minister dominic
grab yesterday when i asked him if he
wouldn't ignore me outside number 10
later in the morning well he may not
have answered my question but the
guardian do have a picture of the wink
he treated me too
instead
there you go the times um
yeah you really did the thymes have a
rather lovely picture this morning of a
mother blue tit feeding its fledgling in
derbyshire these particular chicks can
eat up to a hundred caterpillars every
single day that's a lot of work to be
done isn't it
and uh sophie found these pictures for
us as well
boris johnson croissant dedicated to him
by a grateful ukrainian cafe and if you
fancy one of those for breakfast it's
too bad by late morning they had already
sold out it's an apple pie with some
meringue and ice cream and frankly i
could eat that over and over and over
again
after my fish and chips now i know as
russia moves closer to capturing the
donbass region we'll speak to the former
commander of the joint forces command
that's general richard barrons
[Music]
hello again everybody our top stories
for you this morning on the breakfast
show here on sky news as thousands of
rail workers prepare for the biggest
strikes since 1989. the government says
it's disappointing
boris johnson prepares to face
parliament for the first time since the
damaging revolt by his own mps under
pressure to cut taxes
and two british fighters captured by
russian forces and accused of being
mercenaries appear in court with a
moroccan man on charges that carry a
possible death penalty
[Music]
maurice here morning thoughts morning
kay yes could be a bruising outing for
boris johnson at prime minister's
questions this lunch time i expect
labour will be taunting him about the
fact that 40 percent of the mps sitting
behind him voted no confidence in his
leadership imagine kirstama will go to
town on that he may even read from some
of the letters and comments made by
conservative mps which were particularly
scathing in the run-up to that vote
we'll also see whether boris johnson
gives any indications there about the
direction he may go in in the light of
this threat to his leadership whether he
talks about tax cuts which is now
something a lot of people in the party
are clamoring for but with a lot of
discussion about whether there's going
to be a reshuffle whether he's going to
change his top team as well as the
direction and we asked sajid javid the
health secretary whether the prime
minister prizes loyalty above competence
and experience and this is what he said
no i think
we'll come to that actually uh
what is ready for us to share with our
viewers at this stage is his comments
about ovarian cancer
and the sorry
yes sajid javid also he's here to talk
about a big review into nhs leadership
but we asked him about a change to some
of the wording on the nhs website on the
pages about ovarian cancer which used to
say it is very common cancer in women
but it's now been changed to say ovarian
cancer affects the two small organs that
store the eggs needed to make babies and
this has been criticized including by
some health experts who say that by
changing it to not mention the word
women that may be well intentioned to be
more inclusive to trans men for example
but that it could risk confusing people
about a cancer which is often
misdiagnosed and often detected very
late and it was interesting the health
secretary said that he thought this was
the wrong decision and he would be
asking the nhs about it we had a similar
route a few months ago about cervical
cancer as well and um sajid javid said
that he wanted something to be done
about it this is what he said
and i don't think it's right you know
you won't be surprised to know that as a
health secretary i think that your uh
that your your sex matters your
biological sex is incredibly important
to make sure you get the right treatment
the very best treatment you've given an
example of ovarian cancer i could
equally uh pick a prostate cancer
which which we know can only happen for
those that are biologically male and so
it's important that that when messaging
is is given to people you know for
cancers that's a great example that
you've picked that that words like women
and men are you so that people know who
you're talking about and and then we can
actually do something about it
well that's what he says whether he has
any sway over that the the government
clearly have a different view on this to
the view that the nhs takes and and the
nhs gave it a quote to the times
newspaper who highlighted this saying
that women are mentioned i mean i've had
to look through you have to go quite far
down before they are and that um that
using inclusive language they believe is
important so whether ministers have any
sway on that we'll see tomorrow's take
at nine o'clock pm queues later on
that's going to be pretty bruising we'll
talk about it at nine o'clock for now
tomorrow thanks very much uh before that
though i want to talk about the related
situation in ukraine concerns about how
to get the grain out of ukraine whether
there can be a corridor uh in the black
sea where there's going to be safe
passage for the grain to get out of
ukraine if that doesn't happen there is
significant concerns
about people in africa and also asia who
may well starve let's speak to general
richard barrons former commander of
joint forces command hello to you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us this morning how big a worry is it
about this grain corridor whether or not
it happens
it's it's a major worry it's one of the
most
damaging effects of this war is that the
grain that ukraine normally supplies to
africa asia and elsewhere is not getting
out by sea and there's so much of it
that if you try to move it by by rail it
takes two years to get one year's crop
out so in order to contain the effects
of this war one way or another that
grain has to get out
more than 100 days since this war first
began how much longer can it last
well there's no there's no script and
there's no rule that says a war like
this with a front line that's a thousand
miles long is is going to quit but it's
going to be quick it may have pauses and
we may see in the donetsk in a couple of
weeks if the russians feel that they've
got as far as they want to go or simply
run out of steam that there is a pause
but that does not mean that the fight is
over and we should expect this war to
continue well into next year even if it
comes and goes a bit
okay russian defense minister um saying
that russia has now liberated 97
of the luhansk region um
first of all do you think that can be
true and secondly if that is the case
does that then lend itself to the
argument that you just put forward which
means that there could be a pause
so i think we're at a we're at a very
telling point now uh russia occupies
about 20 percent of ukraine and 97
of luhanskan and close on at least 85
percent of the donbass region
as a whole and the absolute key question
is
when russia feels that it has gone as
far in the donbass as it needs to go and
it is fighting this brutal grinding
battle expending vast amounts of
ammunition and councils to get there has
it run out of steam or does it simply
decide to pause before coming back
elsewhere this year and we won't know
the answer to that for some time on
balance it looks like in the donbass
they're running out of steam
why is the russian invasion having such
an impact on global resources
well i think we looking at the combined
effects of the isolation of of russia
and the sanctions regime that's applied
to russian energy and then the effects
on um global food markets particularly
grain as a result of the blockade on
ukraine and indeed the difficulty in
getting grain out of out of russia and
we need to recognize that in a world of
globalized supply chains any any big war
between
big countries is going to ripple across
the world in this sort of way and and
the fact is we're going to have to
manage the consequences of this if we're
going to do the right thing by ukraine
um okay
we've been hearing from um zielenski he
does his nightly address doesn't he to
the ukrainian people um and very many
ukrainians have also tried to flee the
country
even if there was a pause now how long
do you think it would take to start
to rebuild that country uh of ukraine
and for people to start to return there
so i think we should be clear that
there's a pause as a result of perhaps
russia deciding to stop or run out of
steam is not a pause in any way for
ukraine ukraine will want to build the
military capability that it needs to go
on the offensive and take its country
back and whether that's this year later
on or more likely next year that's the
thing that will be in our laps next that
process of rebuilding the ukrainian
military to throw the russians out is at
least a year's work and will cost a lot
of money and a lot of effort from the
west but that's the demand that's going
to come
how wise is it to provide
weapons that could be used although the
ukrainians have said that they won't
could be used to fire into russia
i think with the war at the stage it's
now in so well developed in ukraine
quite a lot of this is priced in by all
sides i think what would make a
difference clearly would be if western
delivered weapons with long range long
range typically 150 to 300 kilometers
was actually used by ukraine to fire
into russia that i think
would would change the way russia
approaches this but the current
understanding that ukraine is given
weapons that give it the long range it
needs to to destroy russian artillery
before it destroys them but does not far
into russia i think that's a place that
most people will essentially live with
um okay it's good to talk to you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us thank you
we're just talking there weren't we
about the ukrainian president uh
vladimir zelinski he's claimed more than
31 000 russian soldiers have been killed
in ukraine since the war began in
february
ukrainian forces are still managing to
hold on to some territory in the cities
of sever donetsk and lisey
in nearby solidar emergency workers
offering civilians safe passage along
the so-called road of life here's our
chief correspondent stuart ramsey who
traveled with them and sent this report
this is a desperate hunt to evacuate
people from frontline villages that look
destined to fall to russian forces in
the coming days they're just a few miles
away
[Music]
emergency services have had calls
pleading for help from people in the
town of solidar
[Music]
they're risking their lives looking for
the people who want to leave but they
can't find them
italian
is the only person left in her apartment
but she won't go
i tell you why don't you want to leave
foreign
[Music]
these towns and villages appear deserted
but there are plenty of people still
here the fighting is intense nearby
people call for help and they just
simply don't turn up to be evacuated
it seems counterintuitive but
more danger the more the bombing the
less people actually want to leave their
homes they prefer to actually stay where
they feel at least safe rather than get
in this truck and go to another city
it means that they just sort of stay
here
[Applause]
see what's going on
we're going because uh
there's a tank position he's the
uh emergency services uh guy who's
showing us around his head and said
basically from that position if they're
firing he'll be in coming here and say
the crews gather to discuss the next
destination
[Music]
we climb on board their enormous rescue
truck it's a form of armored personnel
carrier they call it the capsule it can
seat 17 in the back
we've had to
change direction because the road that
we were traveling down is now seeing
direct fire between the ukrainian uh and
russian forces this truck is so big it
is armored but it's so big it'll take
direct hits potentially from missiles
which would still
destroy it
the crews are already in the midst of
the fighting
but they insist that they'll continue to
go out day after day until they can't go
anymore
nobody knows when that will be
stu ramsey sky news in the donbass
health officials are stepping up efforts
to tackle the spread of monkey pox from
today doctors in england will have to
notify local authorities when they
suspect a patient has the virus joining
us now is dr charlotte hammer fellow in
emerging infectious diseases at
cambridge university hello thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
how concerned should we be about monkey
pox
now the change that we're seeing now is
a change from
non-notifiable to notifiable as you
mentioned so
at the core of that that
is
basically a surveillance measure public
health measure and that means that
doctors and labs need to notify the
local health protection teams when they
have a suspected or confirmed case of
monkey pox
now that is actually the case for a lot
of diseases and that varies by country
so some countries have just a few
notifiable diseases some have almost a
hundred
um
but there are various reasons why a
disease might be notifiable so it could
be it's always that there is a high
public health significance but there
could be anything from um we need urgent
contact tracing for in this case
or it's a disease targeted for
eradication or something similar
in the uk at the moment there are over
30 notifiable diseases and over 60
causative agents so monkey pox is
certainly not alone in this um and at
this point of the outbreak this is
actually quite expected and in a lot of
countries monkeypox has already been
notifiable
why do you think it's spreading so
quickly in the uk as opposed to other
countries
well a lot of what we're seeing right
now um will be a little bit artificial
in terms of we are very actively looking
for cases um and they actually making it
notifiable is exactly doing that as well
so we we have this initial relatively
steep uptick in cases which is
influenced by our looking for cases very
quickly and obviously the uk was one of
the the first countries that saw this
outbreak um so it is a little bit ahead
of other countries there
um should it could it be
made
to be a quarantine issue compulsory
um well that is to a large degree a
legal question um what do you make
mandatory there in terms of isolation in
terms of quarantine um there's certainly
an argument to be made for isolation and
also for quarantine um
particularly for isolation if if someone
is symptomatic but at the core of that
that is a legal question and that will
be handled differently across different
jurisdictions and is already handled
differently across europe
okay good to talk to you thank you
thank you
now chip shops across the uk are asking
norway for more fish to help combat
surging costs rising energy bills and
increasing prices of cooking oil due to
the war in ukraine have pushed up prices
across the global seafood industry
joining us now from norway actually is
the president of the national federation
of fish fryers that's andrew cook crook
hello to you andrews good to talk to you
why are you in norway
i'm over in norway to speak to vessel
owners
there's a lot of vessel owners that
produce what's called h g headed and
gutted fish
which then goes on to further processing
and i'm hoping that myself and a
colleague julie who works for the frozen
c phillips association uh can convince
them that uh swapping to affiliates will
be beneficial to them but also
beneficial to our industry as well
so what you're hoping is that we're
going to get more fish off them but
nevertheless the price of fish is going
up through the roof isn't it um why is
that is that because there aren't enough
there isn't enough for demand
no well
partly they've reduced the quarter in
the burnt sea so that's down by 20
uh there's post pandemic inflation so
troll is running to use more fuel to
catch the fish and that feels very
expensive so that's combined to be uh
double in
the price of fish and unfortunately
we'll like to see a tarry from russian
fish at some points as well so that's
going to further put pressure on us so
we've seen fish double in price but fish
and chip shops haven't been able to uh
double their prices
to the customers and we're trying to
cushion the consumer so we still
represent a very very good value meal
but
we are under a lot of pressure at the
moment
why particularly norway what have they
got that you want i know obviously fish
but why no way
well we talked to iceland as well the
faroe islands and we also think
consumers maybe need to look at some of
the domestic catches well we're quite
happy to put some of the efficiencies
landed by british fleet um through our
fish and chip shots some of the species
that would probably export so there's a
all these things need to happen to to
try and alleviate the problems that
we're facing with the price rises and
we're also asking government to look at
the way that vit's levied on hospitality
because we we've been saying for a long
time it's unfair it penalizes the very
businesses that we should support the
ones that invest in the business the
ones that provide the good jobs and the
rest hospitality is saying the same
thing now so we think now is the time to
change that and
let us get through this in a good shape
so we can help rebuild the economy
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed do you let us know how you get on
thanks
um savers with us now in central london
and i think we sent her to a chippy
there she is hey saba how're you getting
on this morning
good morning kate well it's not often
that first thing in the morning that my
stomach yards for a plate of fish and
chips but here we are there's a first
time for everything but in more in all
seriousness i'm here today because the
fish and chip
industry are really
struggling now the key components that
make this british delicacy hail from
believe it or not russia and ukraine
where there is obviously a war that is
waging uh in in that part of the world
now just to give you a little bit of
insight into why chippies are struggling
with soaring costs as andrew there was
talking about is that certain things
have have rocketed so if we look at fish
and chips uh the fish 40 of it
of whitefish comes from russia we're
talking haddock and cod
with chips the potato fertilizers have
trebled in price again because they also
come from russia sunflower oil equally
has
gone up in price now uh one business
that i am with uh right now that i'm
here with uh have been impacted by the
cost uh uh impact and i'm now with
philip
inzani who is the business owner uh
polo and um
tell me how you
as a business owner cafe manager has
been impacted
by the exponential rise
in cost
to the industry
well unfortunately we've had to put the
prices up to our customers by about a
pound on a dish of fish and chips
because
literally every day something is
increasing whether it's like you
mentioned before the oil
the potatoes the all the components are
going up and in order for us to be able
to stay afloat we are having to increase
prices to the end user
and um if there were alternatives uh
that were on offer
for example the you know british
industry are now looking to reserve
source from scandinavia
would this benefit from
shops like yours well i think anything
that can be done to help the industry
would be welcome because obviously
this is not the end of the
as it were so
we haven't got any more governmental
help that we had during kobe that's all
finished so if there are initiatives
that are going on that can help us so be
it that would be very welcome brilliant
philip thank you so much
while the the future of this british
staple remains unclear for the moment
and the face of fish and chips as we
know it know it may change unless there
are more alternatives uh available okay
so we're just gonna have to wait and see
really good luck to andrew okay the only
thing missing from your fabulous report
is the fish and chips where are they
well okay it's about 7 55 in the morning
so uh
we haven't had any customers making that
order just yet i think
here's the thoughts about you order it
for the next hour and i'll sub you for
it okay
we'll see you then
brilliant thanks a lot take you up on
that thank you okay looking at the
weather for you is it fish and chip
weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the answer is it's always fish and chip
weather heavy showers longer spells of
rain today before turning unseasonably
windy by friday especially in the
northwest
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now most of us will have seen our fair
share of disruption driving on busy
roads but how about
this
this was the scene in oklahoma city on
monday that's right that is a cow
that you can see running loose along the
road and yes that is a cowboy attempting
to wrangle it in fact succeeding he's
then joined by another cowboy and
together they were able to rescue the
animal from the busy main road oh there
he goes
hopefully he's okay
i'm going to see you at the top of the
hour talking about ovarian cancer stay
tuned
[Music]
you